i don't think i can do that but he did
and that's why tom holland got wrecked
doing stunts for uncharted mark actually
hit me in the teeth
with a sword and as he did his backswing
he like clipped me in the teeth but
wahlberg has been on the defense next
time don't get in the way of my sword
then there was the plane sequence the
car would sort of zoom towards me i
would hit it and then fly off it took a
long time to get right and how many
times did he do this a whopping 17. my
mom's sort of coming up to me on like
the 12th take like do you not think
they've got it already can't they move
on and of course the flying through the
air portion at times i'd be like a
hundred feet in the air is spinning
shooting in spain wasn't so smooth i did
quite a gnarly jump over a railing in in
barcelona my whole right side was like
black and blue and the uncoolest injury
happened to be the one that left holland
unable to work for a whole weekend i got
really bad tendinitis in my hamstring
which isn't a very cool injury that's
just from overwork